hello folks I was speaking to you from
the rather small but very cozy fourth
bedroom of my my house at the moments by
reason of all the rubbish is going on in
the world so talking about functional
programming in JavaScript my contact
details are there on the screen at the
moment feel free to grab them if
anyone's interested I'll try and put
this back up at the end I'm around on
social media and available if anyone has
any further questions slash abuse to
hurl at me so I'll move on a little bit
about me I've been doing software
development for about 15 years now
started off working for a little mobile
application development company here in
my hometown where I had to do stuff like
develop a mapping system for buses which
was great because I had to test it by
going for a walk around the local park
repeatedly absolutely had to is the only
way to do it
then moved on to Capgemini where I
worked on the system the made sure that
everyone in the UK pays the taxes and of
course I've never had any abuse for that
the works was a big book shop firm in
the UK proto labs their manufacturing
company for the US and Europeans are now
recently I have become one of those
contractors that your mum always warned
you about so I'm working for all sorts
of people at the moment I'm a big fan of
films so I don't have so much have a
schedule as a program of events and we
are going with the slightly inaccurately
named six w's who what where when why
and how a functional programming so
first off who is it I'm going to
introduce three people significant to
the history of functional programming
one of these guys is a software
developer see if you can guess which as
we go around but this first gentleman is
Alonzo Church he I didn't have anyone
who can see my Mac and focusing my mouse
pointer
I'll take your silence as a yes okay
wonderful sorry didn't how interactor we
are this is the first of these I've done
so this gentleman is significant for a
few reasons
amongst them for us as developers is
this guy the arrow function that's what
this is it's an arrow function this is
mathematics though this is from an old
mask paper from the fifties and the
second is this guy here this donator
parameter it's the Greek letter lambda
and this is where we get the term lambda
expression this is Haskell Curry who has
something like three programming
languages named after him and we're
interested in him for this which are
beginning to later this is currying
don't worry about what that means at the
moment
now this guy might well be a software
developer
imagine why we think that this is John
McCarthy he developed arguably the first
functional programming language in the
whole world
Lisp in the 1960s so what his functional
program not the point of the last few
slides was to point out that it's not
new there's nothing new about functional
programming in fact I started digging
into the maths papers that formed the
foundation of functional programming and
they date back to the late 1800s
honestly I can't understand a single
thing written in any of them because I'm
not a mathematician I'm an engineer I
don't understand it frankly but it isn't
new at all it's not like the latest
version of angular react or whatever
it's not the latest framework that's
competing with the others it's old it's
been around for a long time the first
programming language dates back to the
60s and most of the heavy works dates
back actually to the 50s it's not
actually a language it's a paradigm a
paradigm is a style of programming in in
a way if we want the metaphor of a
guitar then we may take our guitar and
we may play many forms of music on its
we can play rock we can play pop we can
play country if you have no soul
whatever but the point is that you could
take your language and do many things so
similarly with our programming language
we can do procedural we can do object
orientated we can do functional and an
awful lot of languages these days
support all three JavaScript
particularly support functional very
well and what is it also not it is not
imperative nor is it object orientated
most of the folks that I found that
struggle with understanding are the
folks that have been doing object
orientated for 10 plus years and find it
hard to adopt to a slightly new style of
work it's not the solution to all of our
problems although I would argue it's the
solution to many as hopefully I will
demonstrate over the coming 40 minutes
or so it's also not difficult
and argue it's really not it means
dropping some preconceptions and
learning a slightly new way of looking
at a dev but it's not necessarily
difficult so what actually is it there's
a whole load of concepts a lot of these
have got rather strange complicated
names although what they actually mean
generally isn't all that hard to grasp
immutability this just means that once
you've set a variable you can't change
its state in the JavaScript world pretty
much just means stick const on nearly
everything and stop using less over
higher-order functions this is something
that folks in the JavaScript community
have been doing for ages compared to
folks over in like dotnet and Java this
is passing around functions as if they
were variables either as parameters to a
function as the return from a function
however but that's all it is function as
functions passed around as variables it
emphasizes functions not statements no
what does that mean a statement is
something like an if it's aware it's a
for anything of that sort generally
speaking as a rule of thumb and
functional programming if there is a
question the answer is usually functions
more functions and that holds
surprisingly true for a lot of
situations referential transparency this
means that a function does not rely on
anything beyond its parameters and the
consequence of this is that it becomes
extremely predictable in its behavior
it means that given the same parameters
it will always return the same answer no
matter what no matter the life of the
universe no matter the state of the
system now let's switch it off no matter
anything so this makes it very very very
testable very predictable recursion I'm
hoping we're all good on recursion if
we're not going to dwell on recursion
much in this talk but you know yeah it's
an important T pattern-recognition
we'll come to that this is kind of like
a case statement with knobs on
stateless there's no state
object-orientated tends to rely on the
paradigm of you've got your state object
you update it and you keep touching this
same state object we don't generally do
that in the functional world there are
reasons amongst them it and one of the
great benefits it brings you is that
things like a sink become very easy to
support because you don't have a shared
state between functions there are other
ways
now the monads monads is the one that
has a reputation for being an awful pain
in the bum to understand and certainly
if you go looking on Wikipedia and some
of these slightly more math see sites
you will see these really horrid
definitions of monad that involve F of G
is G of their or whatever I don't really
know I don't understand I'm not a
mathematician but it's going to Douglas
Crockford the curse of the monad is that
once you gain the ability to explain it
you lose once it once you gain the
ability to understand a monad you lose
the ability to explain it so not really
necessarily planning to and it is not
difficult as I'm hoping I'll demonstrate
over there over this talk so where is it
where do we find it there are of course
the pure functional languages ask all
Erlang L never used them personally I
know some folks that swear by Haskell
airline I think it has got its uses all
over I believe there are some queueing
systems out there that are written in
airline RabbitMQ I think that's an
airline
my support functional programming with
each iteration of dotnet that gets
released and it's working out pretty
well and they've even got a mostly
functional language F sharp which is an
alternative to c-sharp BB whatever and
of course JavaScript JavaScript
definitely does support functional very
well when is it so when is it
particularly good it's good for data
processing that is given this data turn
it into this data that's the sort of
thing functional does really well that's
very pure that's not requiring much
interaction concurrent systems that is
it's where you want to stack a whole
load of instances of the same function
side by side there's no shared state so
concurrency is very enabled by
functional high criticality because
functional programs in general tend to
be more robust than object orientated or
procedural code so if it's very
important your system go up and stay up
then functional might well be something
to consider allegedly with stuff like a
Erlang once you've actually got it fir
to compile then nothing on this earth
will ever make it break now I don't know
I've not tried that but it seems
entirely plausible and server lists if
we're interested in service mostly for
the the previous three reasons that's
again functional is the sort of thing
that might easily enable you to get into
service
so where is it not now it's not that
functional can't do these things it's
just that these are some of the areas
where you have to make compromises you I
obviously because there is nothing more
important impure as it gets to the
computer world
now obviously JavaScript off is obvious
often meant to be out on the front line
with the user but what we need to do
generally is maximize the pure area of
functionality and then minimize the
amount of dirty human interaction
external interactions with other systems
same sort of reason input/output
interacting with files because who knows
that the file is there is not there
whatever this is all and high-performing
hey I don't know why that oh yes
high-performance systems because
sometimes it depends this might not be
the case with JavaScript so much with
some systems with some programming
languages certainly let's see sharp
making it more functional may not
necessarily be functionally the most
performant choice but this may not be
the only concern you have when
developing your system often we're more
interested in testability in
sustainability readability if you're
more interested in those things which in
fairness I would again review that most
businesses are because most businesses
are keen that the development efforts
get done fast rather than anything else
then again functionally still probably
what you want so why is it why why are
we interested it's concise you can now
normally our gesture wildly with my arms
but you have to imagine that at the
moment but note you can compress pages
of code down to just a couple of lines
potentially it's a lot more concise than
old-fashioned object orientated
procedural code it's more readable
mostly because of the concision that
you've added in with compacting the code
write down and it tends to enforce the
writing the code in an order of
operations that's more logical and
with what we're actually trying to we're
trying to achieve a testable mention
that and concurrency I've mentioned that
and robustness hey and it's fun I hope
everyone will agree by the end so this
is an old-fashioned bit of
object-oriented 2d procedural code ever
if I gave everyone five seconds to
understand what on earth this was doing
you'd probably struggle and there's a
good and that's because our order of
operations is all over the place there's
all sorts of bits of code structure in
there that are just there to be
structure it's it's a bit harder to read
then say something oh sorry I'll go on
to that in a moment sorry slides for
order to change there okay but in
functional we could just write this on
about a line or so so this is my test
case this is what I'm actually feeding
into the thing so this is a test I what
I'm actually doing is I'm taking a small
little CSV of the titles of Doctor Who
stories for those unfamiliar doctor who
is the greatest TV series in the entire
world and this is the story titles from
the first series in 1963 along with my
personal rating of those stories so what
I actually want to get out of it is pass
this down to data structure and then
take out my favorite stories and then
give us back the titles which is what
this lot is actually doing you know
slightly convoluted way and this is how
I would do it functionally if anyone's
think
is just an awful lot of out-of-the-box
es6 functions there yet pretty much
that's what it is
and if you've been developing in this
style you've pretty much been doing
functional programming for a while now
and what how are we doing again the
order of operations is nice and simple
and laid out in a flow split on new line
then split each of those lines on karma
do a filter where I'm pausing item two
to an INT and then checking it to before
and then finally select out just item
one easy that's an awful lot more
compact than the first code sample it's
a lot easier to read and understand what
it's done it's a lot easy to modify
because we can easily just throw an
extra line into this functional flow
it's obvious where to make a change in
our and that's what functional
programming is what we want to do in
effect is put the rest of our language
into this structure in order to continue
and I'll demonstrate using some one of
my favorite libraries eyelid juice in a
moment and
I did say that I would get into it the
concept of currying so in a normal non
curried function we let's say an ad we
taken into oh there should be a bar I
may possibly have reuse these slides
from another language don't tell anyone
we've got a VAR a if RB and we're just
saying it goes to a plus B so that's
easy give it a 10 20 we get a 30 if this
were a hypothetical curried ad and we
gave it only the 10 does anybody out
they want to hazard a guess as to what
we get out as the value of answer to
well the answer in fact is that you get
back
function because as dolphin in
JavaScript in functional programming the
answer is a function or functions so if
you give this curried add simply one
parameter to the ten you get back a
function which kind of demonstrating
here which has the one firm value filled
in and the second still required and
that is a parameter to the function
that's been returned
so by giving our ad a single parameter
we've converted it into an ad ten
function and this seems a bit strange
but it is in fact very very powerful and
then you can just give it the second one
the you can call this answer to function
give it a second parameter and you get
back at am so finally so the way to die
or we could introduce this to JavaScript
is by one of my very favorite libraries
in the whole world this is RAM - Jas I'm
a huge fan of this guy and most of the
rest of the talk is going to be using
Ram de which I'm a big fan of this
provides an awful lot of functions that
are very similar to things that like
underscore or low - give you but given a
more a more distinctly functional and
approach and using currying on
everything by default so this is an
example of a ram - function this is one
filling in all the parameters n here so
Ram D uses it and what to call a
namespace are generally I mean when
you're importing it you can call it what
you like of course but R is as good as
anything so our dough enth says give me
this array and I will give you the
whatever is in the nth position
nice and simple so all it means is in
the wolf position or whatever you're
you're getting that item so Julie wrote
one it's that one
so we're saying one is the position data
is the data it gives back a capital B
because that isn't one that's there so
far so good
but what we can do is we can only give
it the one we haven't given it the data
at this point so what that means is that
get array one here is now a function
it's a function that given any array fed
into it it will give you whatever is in
position one in that array so now I've
defined to erase data one and A two two
and I'm forming an array here down here
which is a call to get array one here
with data one fed in in the data two so
I'm reusing the exact same code to fetch
the first item out of each so we end up
with an array at the end which is a B
and an F a B from this one left this one
and have defined in one position what
the logic is for turning my reins from
the data that I want this is a
ridiculously simple example and wouldn't
necessarily do this in the real world
but it's just to demonstrate the
principle and you could just easily
slide it into my existing functional
chain here are the enth one here because
everything in ram de unless you supply
every single parameters of the thing
evaluates generally to another function
so this is my arrow function simplified
without the arrow into a simple call to
enth one and what I'd like to do is to
try and pop the rest of this structure
into this same use this same approach to
compact it down and hopefully simplify
further what we're actually trying to do
but first I need to introduce another
structure that I'll be using so I used
to work for a US company and be British
one of the things we would often do is
discuss the weather
because this is no joke what British
people do a lot so the American folks
would say and I'm not doing the accent
because I can't and it's embarrassing
but they would say something like it's a
hundred degrees outside now I would
think a hundred degrees ooh that's hot
enough to boil water what the hell
but of course they mean a hundred
Fahrenheit the system used as further
Minh we're only within the US so the
formula for converting from Fahrenheit
to Celsius is deduct 32 multiplied by 5
divided by 9 because of course it is why
wouldn't it be for what we have is a
series of operations here and each one
is taking a value operating on it
storing that somewhere and then the next
line is taking the previous step
modifying it further and so on step two
step two step like a relay race now
because of that we've got an awful lot
of code noise here we've got all these
contests that actually we're never gonna
use aside from just in this one instance
this a zone used here this B only here
we've got the returned and so on here
well look just really speaking all this
we don't really need we could use a
perfectly nice structure and rambling
which I will be getting to but first Ram
de does have an add subtract multiply
divide it has all of these guys so we
can start throwing these into functional
trees as well these of course are all
curried so if we simply wanted to add or
multiply then it's very easy to create a
quick curried version of those if we do
the adds and call our pass only attend
to it then we add 10 easy-peasy we've
got a tad tent function similar with the
multiply because the order of operations
doesn't matter with these guys but with
the subtract and the divide the order of
operations is important when I say
subtract 2015 here this is 20 minus 15
it's actually in the order that you
would sort of say it's when you're
describing describing a mathematical
operation they divide some leaves
they're a hundred divided by five
so if we want to curry these guys we
probably want to actually change the
order of operations or to curry a
function other than let's say provide
other than the the second one is our
parameter to our resulting curried
function so lambda has a feature here
called Auto it's an underscore
underscore that's actually two
underscores this is a function that is a
special case well its meaning is really
subtract I am supplying all of the
parameters but I'm saying that the one
that the curry function that comes out
of it should actually supplies as
parameter is the one I'm saying I'm
saying this is the whole this is the bit
that needs to be filled in by the next
call to the function we're generating so
by doing this I'm saying please now yet
next person supply the first one and
then I'll give you the 15 so that in a
fact means I've now created a ooh that's
wrong that's wrong I've now created a
subtract 15 function and down here again
I am telling the thing that this is the
one I want to be supplied later so I've
now just created 8/5 function easy so
then finally we could put all of this
stuff into my new Fahrenheit to Celsius
converter using something called pipe
and pipe does exactly the process that
you saw on the old version of this code
it's now bearing in mind of course as
again with almost everything around it
this is a function so our top pipe is a
function that takes a single parameter
which is whatever it is that's been
supplied in which hopefully is a number
you probably want to actually do some
validation of that in the real world but
I'll keep it means a little simple here
so other pipe takes our single parameter
which will be our hundred degrees and
then it passes it to the first function
in the chain which is a subtract and
we're filling in the blank here so it's
taken whatever that parameter pass
is filling it in they're subtracting 30
to whatever the result of that is pipe
will now push it in to this one 2 x 5
whatever the result of that is will push
into here and then we'll fill that final
value here and divide it by 9 this in
its very simplest form is a monad in
case anyone was interested there's more
to a monad than this but this is the
very simplest version of that that
concept a relay race just a series of
operations each one passing a value to
the next after operating on it until
finally we collapse out to a final value
at the end and returning to our our
function here this is our parser so if
we wanted to convert all of this into a
rounded up structure we can now use our
pipe yep there we go like that so pipe
says give me the value then I will do
our dot split and again all of these are
curried functions these all generally
take one more parameter than you're
seeing here and that final parameter is
almost always the value of the data on
which to operate so I am splitting on
new line then I'm doing a map and our
dot map is just the same as a map as
we're used to it and into that I'm
passing the function artists split so
split on new line split each line of
that on comma then a filter which is
filling it in longhand there I'm
actually creating a territory function
to do that there's probably a smarter
way but that's no that's good enough to
me and finally a mod map where and
passing it are dense which is that means
go through the entire array and select
out the first item pramukh and
functionally this is exactly identical
to all the previous versions with the
pars you've seen you can run this
through unit tests you'll get the
precise same results but this is a bit
more compact and we're relying a lot
more on code that someone else has
provided for us
so moving on to another sort of example
of the the sort of functional structures
we we would do this is a password
validator it's a password validator with
a series of rules but it's quite long
it's got a lot of repeated structure
with these early return falses and we
could compact this down a whole load
make this a bit easier to follow because
I've seen how out of hand these things
can get if you let them I've seen
functions of this sort that end up
growing so much that they end up looking
like family trees and the functional
structure will tend to restrict people
in terms of how much of that sort of
craziness they try so we've got our
rules which must not be
not be undefined and then convert to a
string and then we're saying it must be
a less than or equal to two it must be
greater than ten it must not be Justin
Bieber because it must not so that first
bit is e that last bit sorry is easy a
function in RAM de to determine whether
something equals Justin Bieber is easy
that's just our dot equals so this again
is a curried function so whatever you
pass into is evil now it will evaluate
it against this and to tell me whether
or not it's it's the same this is what
we've actually generated behind the
scenes but if we want to find out if it
is not that if we want to reverse the
the logic of that's that function then
add a compliment is what we would use so
hard at compliments
takes a function that returns boolean
and then it returns you back another
function but one which does the opposite
of that so this r dot equals checks
whether we are equal to Justin Bieber
they are the complement of that a checks
that we are not equal so it is not X is
triple equal to Justin Bieber easy and
if we wanted to assert against
properties well that's not too difficult
either
this prop eke does exactly that it says
that this sir here gets back a function
which asserts that the property B is
equal to capital B so if we were to feed
this function this object we get back a
true because it does have a B and a B so
that's fine but the property that we
want to assert against is length and we
don't want to say that it's equal to
something we want to say that it's
within a range now there is actually
another function for doing this in
Rambla and that's prop satisfies and
what prop satisfies requires is wouldn't
you know it a function which is the
that's the predicate that we're saying
has to be met in order for this prop
satisfies to return true so we're saying
that whatever this property is it has to
be greater than 2 here we're saying that
the property we're asserting against his
length so this now has returned a
function which will check the length of
any given object you pass to it and
assert that it's length is greater than
2 and we can go step further and just
use our GT greater than and pass it to
and we've got back exactly the same
thing so this then is the new version of
my password rules so I'm using a
structure here called our dot all now
all would be they're certainly very
familiar to me from my c-sharp days and
what all means is I am going to give a
whole list of functions and I'm going to
evaluate them one after the other and
given that any of them return false then
I will terminate the sole thing early
and return out false and in this case
what we're doing is this again is a
single parameter function this whole
thing validate password is a function
which takes a single parameter which is
our data which will be hopefully our
password one second
sorry so and it's pressing that same
value one after the other into each of
these functions I have generated so the
first is actually an r dot is nil and
this is our capture all check against
whether the the value be a variable is
defined or not and I'm doing the RDoc
complement of it so this effectively
means first check that this thing is
undefined or whatever and this thing
means do the inverse so what I'm saying
is that I'm actually saying that all of
these things have to be true in order to
be validated so this is in effect it's
not nil it's not undefined it's not
whatever r dot is is so flippin useful
that I would used all over the place and
this is passing the type as it were that
you wish to check it to be and it'll
tell you whether that's true or not so
I'm saying R that is string so we've
passed in our password we're checking
that it's not undefined now we're
checking that it's a string so the rest
of the predicate can't continue
safely on the assumption that this is a
string because otherwise once we start
checking in its length it could be an
array or who knows what
so prop satisfied I'm saying greater
than 2 and prop satisfied less than or
equal to 10 so that's our lengths
satisfied and also that it is not Justin
Bieber because he must not be so all of
that
I set a password rules but again written
in a fairly nice fairly easy to read way
it's very easy to understand how exactly
to modify if if I were ever to throw in
a new rule it would literally just be an
extra one line in this structure or
maybe a modification and it's I would
argue it's a lot easier to work with I
mean there is a little bit of the
overhead of this I dot business but once
you pass that the rest of it's quite
easy to work with so another example
require us to do some slightly different
work and this is something that probably
an awful lot of us and the programming
base will be familiar with and that's
fizzbuzz for those unfamiliar in them
I'm not thinking there's gonna be many
of you this is a very simple game where
we write out numbers if one of them is
divisible by 3 we add fears if it's
divisible by 5 we add buzz if it's
divisible by both like 15 we add
fizzbuzz I don't know why but this this
is the go-to coding exercise I often get
set in interviews [ __ ] so how do
we do this using our functional rammed a
code
well first off we'll need a map of
course and I will get on to exactly what
the implementation of this cat this is
this is the thing that says given a
number here's the output that I'm going
to give you either a number or a string
I'll get into that in a second but first
we're generating a range now the range
is saying generate me an array between
Oh lengths water between which has
values in it between 1 and whatever num
is whatever the whatever the highest
number that you want in my previous
example it's 20 so this is generating as
an array of integers between 1 and 20
and then using map we're feeding each
and every one of those into this
function here
so another structure to introduce that's
the if-else we'll be using that in just
a moment and this is a handy little kind
of like logical switch statement and
this again is a function and takes a
single parameter like everything else
and it's saying first off whatever the
parameter is pass it in to the first
item in the structure that's in my case
it's R equals 5 so what it's saying is
whatever they've been passed into this
function here pass it here and this will
tell me whether or not it equals 5 if it
does equal 5 then pass it
to this function and do the
transformation now always means that's
what it always returns so always means
disregard the parameter and just return
this so if it is five we get back fi b
e5 as a string otherwise pass the
parameter into this one identity now
identity actually also means disregard
the parameter well no it doesn't what it
means is take the parameter and just
return it completely unmodified so a
little if-else structure here is saying
take a parameter check whether it's five
if it's five return back the text of
five otherwise if it was three let's say
then return that back that three exactly
as it was without touching it
so moving on we've got we've got a pipe
here and the pipe is using the if/else
so this is a pipe so it's passing the
parameter this this is the thing that's
called by the map in our previous line
of code so that means that this is
operating on each item in this range
array between 1 and 20 so the parameter
to these is an integer between 1 and 20
its operating on each one individually
one after the other and it's checking
them against these rules it's saying
first is it divisible by 3
I'll get onto that in a moment and if it
is do add up concatenate I'm putting the
hole here to say my original item goes
here and then we append fears otherwise
if it is not divisible by 3 then our
identity that means return the original
value back unmodified similarly here if
it's divisible by 5 then we concatenate
buzz so that's a pipe and we are either
a concatenated a 3 we concatenate F is
where are all of buzz or if neither of
those divisible x' were true then we're
simply returning identity an unmodified
value so that's all of our logic for
doing our fizzbuzz pretty much in that
one statement needing diddly is
divisible by by the way looks a bit like
this and that's a pipe where we pass it
math mod is our modulus behaving in a
mathematical way which apparently the
the percentage in JavaScript doesn't
always we're saying pop the value there
num is 3 or 5 as appropriate and then
we're saying return back whatever this
was passed into equals compared here at
0 so there we go that's a divisible by
one of the last time
examples so this is a card game that was
introduced to me as pontoon but apparent
in the u.s. it's known as blackjack I've
also heard it called twenty one and a
few other names but the basic idea is
that you're taking cards one after the
other from the dealer if it's a number
card it's equal to that number if it's a
jack or queen or a king the value of
that is ten the ace actually is equal to
either one or 11 I've simplified a
little because I don't want to get
bogged down too much so I'm saying the
ACE is 11 and the idea is that you're
taking cards to get as close to 21 as
you can but if you go over 21 then
you've lost it it amused me as a kid and
if you wanted to do old scale school
you'd do something like this if
statement stuff all over the place but
all we're doing is the scoring at the
moment my dad is because frankly it's
too useful not to so there is an r dot
contains because i don't want to do big
long strings of ifs looking at Queen
looking at King so on when the answer is
all the same I'd want to do one i want
to compact that a bit further the
problem is our dock contains as it works
in a slightly interesting way for what
I'm used to and that is that first you
say the thing that should be contained
in the array then you pass the array
which is the other way around to what
I'd kind of was kind of like I would
like the array and then I would like to
pass in the thing to check it contains
so all of that just means that we need
to use another r dot underscore
underscore to fill in the turtle it's
fill in the blank here but this is using
another functional structure called
which Ram Dass called cond can't for
condition and each parameter to this
this whole thing is an array and each
item in the array is itself an array a
two-part array the left-hand side of
each of these is a predicate that is
something that takes the parameter
evaluates it and then returns a true or
a false this true or false is does this
rule apply so
our dough is a number means if whatever
the per the parameter is is a number
then simply return it unmodified moving
on to the next line we've got a slightly
more complicated condition and that's it
contains and I'm saying our blank is
here so we're filling in here and I'm
saying look in this array if our value
is contained within this array return
ten so two are two always ten otherwise
if it's an ace and are always for eleven
so this structure this is pattern
recognition this is what it is where
it's kind of like a switch statement but
with full on functional expressions on
the left hand side rather than simply
checking against value and then on the
right hand side again we've got a
full-on function of some kind this sort
of structure is extremely powerful and
can enable you to write an awful lot of
code that would otherwise be complicated
and long-winded and they're moving on
too so if you want to imagine the sort
of basic functional flow we start with
an item let's call it string
generally speaking the first option
either chance you get you split it into
an array of strings or string or
whatever maybe you do aware or something
or a filter rather to reduce the number
select or map rather to convert to
something else then finally aggregate
into a single value again that's the
sort of standard flow that will run
through when we're doing a functional
process but this aggregation is the last
step in the process I haven't really
touched on so far there are some
built-in simple aggregators some we're
doing exactly what you think pass it at
a rate you get back the sum mean it
takes you an average easy but we want to
do something slightly more complicated
we want to take an array of cards in our
hand so in my imaginary example of got a
wire a five and okay so that's one five
and a king Kings worth ten so that's 16
and I want to convert all of this
to a single value of the score and
that's where our dot reduce comes in so
add it reduce takes a function with two
parameters
the accumulator and the value so the
accumulator is the running total so far
and the value is the current item out of
the array it also need to pass it the
starting value which when we're
calculating our scoring cards is is
going to be zero so when we run this the
first time the accumulator will be zero
because that's here the value will be
the first item out of our array which is
a 1 and so we're saying that the new
running total is accumulator that is the
old running total add the score of the
card which is over here that's this
functional we created this this pattern
recognition structure so 1 will go into
scorecard it'll actually match there is
a number come back as identity so the
new running total is 1 so then we'll
call this function again and the new
accumulator is 1 the new value is now 5
and we're saying that that is equal to
the old value that is 1 plus the score
now again it will be 5 so that means
that the new accumulator is 6 calling
this again we've got 6 here and we've
got K here so when that goes into our
score card this will not match so we
won't do identity this won't will though
and it will match on King so that means
we'll bring back a 10 so finally we'll
get back our 16 took me an awful long
time to explain that but didn't take me
very long to write it and once you're
used to working with this pattern it's
not really all that difficult to throw
these together
and if we want to go another step
further more complicated we could do a
pipe which is first which then first as
I reduce which is reducing our array
down from this list of curve cards to a
valium and then do an if else to say if
it's less than or equal to 21 we'll do
identity so that's your actual score
otherwise we'll do it always with bust
so in my examine example if we pass in
the one the five in the king will again
back a sixteen otherwise if we have a
queen in there too now the Queen will
take sixteen to twenty six and that
means that we will switch to being bust
yeah
again awful lot of time to explain not
much time to read or to understand so
this is the last bit and then you can
all relax so I've got a hypothetical DB
get of some description I don't really
know what it's doing I don't really care
and it's getting a record based on an ID
and inside this is a data object of some
kind
it's I'm imagining it's user data or
something of that sort
and I want to say hello to whomever I've
details I've just fetched possibly the
devil and I will call first name or that
put it into a string now that's fine
provided that this actually works
that we actually do have a record coming
out of this and this is not just
undefined because otherwise this is
gonna explode so there is a structure in
functional programming that will allow
us to do this sort of thing without
having to answer a sort in an awful lot
of checks against undefined all over the
place muddying up the code and getting
in the way of understanding what's going
on
this is one way of implementing it I've
seen it done all sorts of other ways but
typically it's called maybe and maybe is
an object that just contains a value I
think of it as a thing in a box so we've
got our value we're popping it inside
the box maybe is the name of the box and
we've got two functions hanging up its
prototype the first is to get Bali which
is just take the thing out of the box
and hand it over and the second is bind
a bind
takes a function and what we do is we
check whether this this value is
actually defined or not if it's not
defined
we will not execute the function we'll
just return another maybe with undefined
contained within it otherwise we'll
return a new maybe and this time we will
execute func whatever this is with the
value from inside our box popped into
that and that's what it would actually
look like when you run it so I'm saying
my message is a new maybe and I'm
starting with my ID and I'm using bind
and passing it in a DB get record so X
here is the six-six-six and that's going
into there and that's executing now if
this worked this means that this would
actually first bind would return a new
maybe with whenever the result of that
is popped into it and then the new maybe
would have a bind on it and this would
be the result of that and then we could
safely operate knowing that this is
defined it might not be a terrible idea
to possibly put a try-catch around it
again just in case first name doesn't
really exist and then finally you called
that value at the end to get the value
out of it
but if on the other hand this return
nothing then
this type of this value would be true
there would be undefined
and we're simply gonna return our new
maybe so that means if DB get record
return nothing this bind will not run
this function here this function will
never be run but an undefined will be
returned so the value at the end will be
undefined
and we can do something like get our
Condor whatever to decide what to do
with it but the point is that I've
written my my flow of operations in this
single chain and I don't need to start
adding in lots of codes to check against
whether the previous operation worked or
not
I can add in as many Trull lines as I
like and all of these can assume that
the previous step have succeeded because
otherwise the step will not be executed
and this is what a monad really is this
is the sort of thing that we really do
with them there's a whole load of other
monads covering all sorts of other other
eventualities
you could have monads which return
different objects depending on where the
previous steps worked or not you could
have monads that switch to containing
error messages and the result that an
error occurred in fact if you've been
messing with promises those are a monad
as well so you may have been using some
of these longer than you expected so
I've got about 10 minutes left which is
not bad timing at all does anybody have
any questions at this point
thanks a lot Simon I am in charge off
the questionnaire site there are
questions for you all well yeah it's not
scary
how many of them contain abuse the first
question is for someone who knows
programming C and Java what do you think
would be the best functional programming
language any books you can recommend for
C and Eve well ok I'm haven't done C
since I was at university and that's
longer ago than I really care to admit
Javad oh I again don't know Java but I
do know C sharp so C sharp is actually a
really good one at the moment for
getting into functional programming
because as I said right at the beginning
Microsoft now have a policy of
introducing more functional abilities to
their language as they go along they
things like the the pattern recognition
it's not entirely as excuse me as
powerful as the structure I showed you
there but it's getting there and I
believe it's something they're
continuing to work on so I would
actually recommend a book called the
it's functional programming in c-sharp
by Enrico banano it's published by
Manning and it's honestly one of the
best programming books I've read in a
very long time I absolutely adored that
book and it's examples of how you can
start doing functional programming and
c-sharp today using no extra libraries
and it explains things like the monad
and the pattern recognition system so
nicely but it's it's easy to work with
and the best thing you can do is don't
just read it grab out Visual Studio or
whatever and and do it because a lot of
the difficulty in understanding
functional programming often comes from
did the concepts and getting your head
around it and if you sit there and do it
I almost guarantee that with after some
time there'll be a light bulb moment and
suddenly it'll all become just obvious
and certainly for me now I get a little
annoyed if I have to write everything
out longhand as it were you know doing
it the old way rather than doing it the
nice quick easy functional way so that's
that's my personal favorite book there
is functional programming in JavaScript
by the same publishers I haven't read
that in a great deal of detail it looked
quite good but it wasn't entirely what I
was after personally it uses underscore
so if you use familiar with underscore
you might find that one useful but
personally lamda is is one of my
all-time favorite libraries for almost
any programming language ever ever so
also I'd recommend check
the Rambler website they have extensive
documentation on how their library works
nice yeah we'll make sure that we'll get
the links for the books and we can
publish them together with the slides
later on
JK Oh tell you what I haven't got my get
up put my camera so that you nice people
hey hello you're currently not visible
though they can only call uestions I can
put your I'm already I'm already married
I'm sorry what do you think of
observable hq.com if you've heard of it
I have not I am really sorry and I'm
literally writing down that right now
because I'm I'm so sorry but I've never
heard of it alright one last question
[Music]
what do you think about rusts again not
heard of that one
apologies to everybody that's a
programming language I think isn't it
so I do not like that in my car I have I
don't know anything about it as a
programming language so again apologies
javascript in c-sharp but predominately
all they ever work in all right that's
all the questions we had thanks a lot
for the talk for me as a Haskell
evangelist ever since I first it's it's
great to see that functional programming
is catching on everywhere nowadays yeah
if in fact I was having a chat with the
summer into it when I was in the US I'd
have a chat with that their summer
interns and they were saying that in
their universities now functional is the
sort of programming that they're
teaching them so I do get the fee and
certainly when I go to things like NDC
Oslo and things like that I get the
impression there is more functional
content each year compared to the
previous and people are starting to name
check at least functional and even in
the non-functional talk so it is
definitely a very coming thing and
something that's becoming extremely
increasingly important as the years go
on
yeah it's nice and thanks again for a
great talk
and with that I would like to thank our
speakers our sponsors and all our
viewers
you